I was in Brighton giving that live talk
and then one of my friends got up on
stage and it was packed 1,600 people
wall to- wall and I just wanted to watch
his show from the front during the
interval this guy comes over we get
talking and he was discussing about how
he has what I called personal growth
guilt Survivor guilt someone goes away
to war all of their friends die you get
to come home and there's a very specific
type of guilt that's associated with
that which is his belief that he should
have gone with his friends he was
talking to me that as he begins to pull
himself away from these beliefs and
insights and Lifestyles that no longer
serve him he was starting to feel this
degree of guilt for leaving his friends
behind I think that this is one of the
drawers that pulls people back into Old
Habits it's interesting now with things
like Facebook where I think it's
becoming increasingly difficult to
distance yourself from the past there
used to be a high school reunion and
you'd meet someone 15 years after you
left school and go what have you been up
to now you already know you don't get to
kind of reinvent yourself and I think
it's quite a healthy thing